[Música]
esta es la historia de un impulso de
como una acción de apenas unos segundos
cambio mi vida era diciembre del año
2011 supongo que algunos de vosotros
habréis visto alguna vez o habréis oído
hablar de este momento
el azúcar
yo resuena el azúcar
se ha acabado
todavía no sé cómo pude hacer una cosa
así
pero bueno hoy ya conocéis este momento
pero vais a saber qué pasó antes durante
y después de este momentazo vais a saber
las consecuencias de aquel impulso lo
mucho que tuve que aguantar lo mucho que
sufrí los acosos pero sobre todo vais a
saber la gran lección de vida que
aprendí de esos famosos segundos
os habéis preguntado alguna vez por qué
somos tan implacables con el error ajeno
esto es divertido simplemente para la
gente famosa políticos deportistas
periodistas o nos gustaría que nuestros
errores el de nuestra familia amigos
pareja se viesen amplificado en las
redes sociales y en la televisión y
fuesen motivo de escarnio y cachondeo
el mundo social media y la televisión te
pueden llegar a destruir simplemente por
una diversión efímera tu trayectoria
profesional y personal se puede ver
reducida a esto
a partir de este momento mi trayectoria
de más de 25 años como modelo
presentadora actriz productora de teatro
se vio reducida a aquella torpe que hizo
perder cinco mil euros a mario
podría haber quedado en una simple
anécdota en un momento televisivo para
poder reírte en los zapping pero no fue
así veréis el gran fernando fernán gómez
en la memoria de muchos ha quedado como
aquel señor enfadado que dijo aquello de
a la [ __ ] váyase usted a la [ __ ] y
otro grande como paco umbral
recordado por aquella mítica frase de yo
he venido aquí a hablar de mi libro
lo más triste de todo esto es que
seguramente muchos nunca acojan un libro
para leerlo de paco umbral y otros de
esos tampoco sepan nunca de la grandeza
intelectual de fernán gómez
a ver yo no me quiero comparar con ellos
pero es que desde ese momento yo me
convertí en la torpe nacional en esa
guapa pero tonta que además había sido
miss españa lo que para algunos es un
plus y menos mal que no soy rubia
puestos a topicazo sé de poco sirvieron
mis disculpas a mario de nada que
quisiera pagarle esos cinco mil euros ni
tampoco que la asumiese que se trataba
de un concurso de un juego y se
resignarse ante mí metedura de pata
fijaos cómo llego a ser esto que hasta
he tenido el dudoso privilegio de que se
acuñe la expresión de hacer un remedio
cervantes para todos aquellos que
cometen un cambio de idea en el último
segundo
han pasado siete años y google me sigue
recordando cada día que yo soy aquella
torpe de los cinco mil euros
pero volvamos al principio el programa
se grabó en el mes de diciembre
obviamente la cadena de televisión que
sabía lo que había ocurrido en ese
programa y con muy buen criterio no
podía perder esa oportunidad es cierto
que se podía haber grabado esos últimos
minutos suele pasar siempre en la
televisión pero no fue así el programa
se emite tal cual la noche del 27 de
diciembre justo
la noche antes del día de los inocentes
eso ya daría pie a muchos a pensar que
aquello era una broma aunque otros
también podrían pensar que aquello había
pasado de verdad de momento ya habían
conseguido el primer impacto
al día siguiente fue todavía mucho peor
para mí cuando se descubrió que aquello
no era una broma
fui trending topic mundial durante algo
más de una semana
aquello le dio al programa una gran
expectación y mucha publicidad ya sabéis
que todo eso se traduce en ingresos
publicitarios principalmente en el
programa al que después volvió a
concursar mario que por cierto tengo que
decir que ganó tres veces más de lo que
había perdido conmigo yo no sabéis lo
que lo que sentí yo estaba feliz por él
yo me sentí aliviada me sentí
reconfortada dije bueno ya está esto ha
terminado aquí borrón y cuenta nueva
voy a pasar página pues no
a ver es cierto que todo esto podría
haber sido un montaje pero señores no lo
fue yo cometí ese error
pero lo único cierto de mi error de mi
equivocación de mi impulso es que pasó
de ser una anécdota televisiva a una
burla nacional y de durísimos ataques
social media menos mal que yo yo como
malagueña que soy y mediterránea soy una
mujer que tiene un gran sentido del
humor y además de recibir muy bien los
ataques y las críticas pero siempre que
venga con un humor inteligente y con la
sorna que nos caracteriza pero es que
todo esto fue a más y a más y a más
hasta que se convirtió en acosos en
ataques personales y profesionales en
peticiones de que no se me volviese a
dar nunca más un programa de televisión
no querían que volviese a trabajar en
televisión e incluso en amenazas muy
desagradables y violentas
y yo me pregunto que puede llevar a
tanta gente a destilar tanto odio y
rencor y violencia verbal
saber que muchos dijeron en las redes
sociales que si pudiesen me darían una
paliza
y lo que es peor
llegué a recibir en mi propia casa una
carta con una amenaza de muerte
la suerte no
sobre todo porque la gente que ni le iba
ni le venía y además todo esto podría
ser perfectamente un montaje
yo cuando escuchaba ese tipo de cosas
como no se estaba intentando pensar en
una cosa que pasó pero no la recuerdo
con un compañero que de repente algo me
contó que le había pasado en las redes
sociales yo le decía bueno este esto a
esto no hay que hacerle caso estos son
cuatro locos qué bueno que hay que
olvidar los digital pero pero a ver una
de dos o en españa hay mucho loco pues
las noches de luna llena gente normal
como nosotros nos convertimos centrol y
nos lanzamos a las redes sociales a
machacar a unos y a otros simplemente
por una diversión
todo esto a mí particularmente me hace
pensar que culpa tenemos cada uno de
nosotros individualmente que culpa
tienes tú
tú el de la pajarita o aquel que está
allí o tú el de arriba cuando además
sabemos que este tipo de cosas
perfectamente pueden estar diseñadas por
las cadenas de televisión los partidos
políticos las marcas las agencias de
marketing porque participamos
nos resulta divertido
quién sabe
si no paramos esa rueda es posible que
siga rodando y rodando y que tal vez
algún día pues un compañero de trabajo
que aspire a nuestro puesto o una pareja
que no nos quiera bien lancia en las
redes sociales esos errores y esos
impulsos que un día cometimos y bueno
da miedo no
a lo mejor alguno de vosotros está
pensando en esto en aquello que hice y
que si saliese a las redes me podría
hacer polvo
pero
no todo fue tan oscuro en la historia de
mi impuesto tuvo sorprendentes puntos de
giro como en las mejores películas y
todo dependía de mí de como yo me lo
tomase de mi reacción veréis por un lado
podía haberle plantado y plantado cara
abre me he puesto a denunciar a unos ya
otros
incluso en atacar a la cadena o ponerme
un impermeable esconderme dentro y
esperar a que pasara la tormenta
y otra cosa podría haber sido tratar de
reconducir todo aquello hacía algo
positivo
opté por la tercera
opté por entender pues que un error yo
me impulsa forma parte de la vida es lo
que nos hace personas opte por verlo
como debía a metabolizar lo con mi
carácter emprendedor y positivo así es
cómo conseguí salir de esa espiral
tóxica que me habían metido gente que ni
conocía ni me conocían de nada
entonces decidí volver al origen
y me pregunte por qué estaba yo invitada
ese día en ese programa de televisión y
justo ahí vinieron todas mis fortalezas
todos esos años de lucha esas noches de
insomnio
esos estudios de guión esas giras de
teatro esos grandes profesionales que
habían confiado en mí durante tanto
tiempo la lucha encarnecida que tuve por
tener mi propia compañía de teatro sense
ice cuenta otro impulso pesado de todo
aquello y me colocó adelante todas las
etapas de mi vida
entonces me dije a ver
si a mí me han gustado siempre las
nuevas tecnologías y las redes sociales
porque no soy yo la que toma el timón
del barco y no la que se deja arrastrar
y decidí aprender estudiar conocer el
mundo de las redes sociales y la
reputación digital
con 47 años nunca es tarde
meza que lo haces universitario me costó
pero me lo jaque
bueno al poco tiempo
murió mi madre
y decidí ahogar esas lágrimas en el
estudio un año hice un curso al
siguiente hice otro al siguiente un
posgrado y por último un máster en
marketing digital y big data que acabe
el año pasado en la universidad europea
de valència y donde este año he tenido
el privilegio de impartir una clase
durante este proceso conocí a dos
personas fantásticas con las que he
montado mi empresa de marketing aquí en
valencia hasta me he venido a vivir a
esta hermosa ciudad que tantas alegrías
me siguen dando
el monstruo de las redes sociales me
quiso devorar
al final conseguí domesticarlo
si os dais cuenta y lo pensáis bien
todos los implicados en esta historia de
alguna manera u otra hemos salido
ganando también es verdad que podría
haber ocurrido cualquier cosa
esta es la historia de mi impulso pero
es mi historia y también podría ser la
de cualquiera de vosotros todo empezó en
las redes sociales pero lo cierto es que
lo está impregnando todo ya no se admite
el error todo tiene que ser blanco o
negro estás conmigo estás contra mí
se está se está perdiendo está en
peligro la riqueza de los matices
y todos estamos llenos de matices
vivimos en un mundo de tormentas
efímeras de polémicas que son
sustituidas a las pocas horas por otras
lo sabemos pero aún así participamos
estamos saturados de información de
contenido el marketing político las
facebook el marketing publicitario el
último caso de cambridge la analítica
de nuestra capacidad de reacción van a
depender muchas cosas principalmente
nuestra salud mental
por eso desde este ciudad bella de
valència yo os hago un llamamiento
para con mucha fuerza agarrarnos al
error al impulso a reivindicarlo al
matiz a la equivocación porque eso es lo
que nos hace más personas tenemos que
rechazar que cada día nos digan lo que
tenemos que hacer o qué decir a quien
machacar y a quién alabar tenemos que
decidir si queremos seguir siendo
acosadores y títeres o por el contrario
ser los que llevemos el timón de nuestro
propio barco
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]